So welcome those of you who are here.
Thanks for coming to our session.
We're going to spend the next hour and a half or so thinking about
generally lifestyle choices in terms of cancer development,
cancer therapy. I'm going to cover diet,
some aspects of diet, exercise, and the
influence of the microbiome. So I'm Karen Valston.
I'm going to give the first talk about precision diets,
and then we have two other speakers, as you see.
So, okay, my slides are up. That's fantastic.
Well, clearly, there's a lot of interest in diet.
Diet and health, diet and disease,
a huge industry.
But I think it's probably fair to say that we still have a lot to
learn about how diet influences cancer
development and the aspect that we're particularly interested in, how
diet can either help to augment
cancer treatment.
So obviously, diet provides all the nutrients
for metabolism in both normal and cancer cells.
So diet is important for all of our tissues, healthy and
diseased. And we know,
obviously, that changes in diet can change the
availability of nutrients and can have
particularly profound effects on our health.
If we think of vitamin deficiencies or mineral deficiencies, it's very
obvious that diet is important for maintaining normal health.
So
many years ago now, while Oliver was in the lab with me, he
decided that he would like to see whether there were any selective
nutritional requirements of cancer cells that we might be able to
harness therapeutically. And he started doing these experiments in
tissue culture systems, looking at the requirements for
nonessential amino acids in a variety of cancer cells.
So he used nonessential amino acids because he didn't necessarily want
to affect normal tissue. And what he
found was that many cancer cells are very
dependent on an exogenous supply of the two
nonessential amino acids, serine and glycine.
Now they are nonessential, which means, of course, that most of
our
cells can make serine and glycine de novo from glucose.
So the first question, of course, is, is it really feasible to modulate
serine and glycine through diet, given that our entire bodies can make serine and
glycine? And we discovered, and many others have confirmed this, that indeed,
if you feed mice on a serine glycine limited diet, you
can reduce the amount of circulating serine and glycine.
And in fact, we have done some trials in normal healthy
volunteers and found that you can also reduce circulating levels of
serine and glycine in people by feeding them on a serine glycine
restricted diet.
So serine and glycine, the reason we use both is because they're very
easily interconvertible through loss or gain of a one carbon unit,
and they're important for many processes.
They're important for
feeding the folate cycle, the one carbon cycle, and the production of
nucleotides. Important in contributing to the
methionine cycle and the methylation of DNA, RNA,
proteins, lipids, all those important processes.
But what we've become particularly interested in is this role of
serine and glycine in supporting
antioxidant defense through both the production of
NADPH, and providing
reducing equivalents for
antioxidative reactions and the production of
glutathione. Of course, one of the principal antioxidants that we have
protecting ourselves from oxidative stress.
So moving on over the next years, Oliver and then later
Vasilis, who's now in my lab, have shown that in many
actual tumor models in mice, you can recapitulate
those in vitro experiments by showing that feeding mice on a serine
glycine free diet can lead to slower
tumor growth, longer survival, and less metastasis in a
number of different genetically engineered models or
orthotopic types of models. So it
seems that at least in these model systems, limiting
serine and glycine through diet can have a therapeutic benefit
just alone.
But obviously we limit tumor growth, but we don't cure the
mice. And so the question then becomes, can we combine the
serine glycine free diet with something else?
Now, as I mentioned a moment ago, serine and glycine are important for
protection from oxidative stress.
And we can see again in tissue culture cells that if we grow
the cells in the absence of serine, they become much more sensitive to
oxidative stress. In this case, we're just giving the cells
peroxide. And so the question then we asked was,
is it possible that serine glycine depletion would cooperate with
chemo or radiotherapy, both of which we know function to
a large part by inducing ROS, inducing oxidative
stress and thereby killing cancer cells.
So would this combination work? And in fact, my lab
didn't do the experiment. Oliver when he went on to start his own lab and did this
nice experiment where he showed that in a tumor model
he could treat the mice with a serine glycine free diet or he could treat
the tumors using radiotherapy. And you can see that there's some
response in terms of the cell death.
But clearly when he uses both a serine glycine free diet and
radiotherapy, that response is greatly enhanced.
So there's a lot more death. So there's some, I think, merit
to the suggestion that there may be a good combination of increasing
ROS and using a serine glycine free
diet.And interestingly, Thalas
Papaji has shown really nicely that
when tumors try to activate their antioxidative
pathways, that in itself produces a
requirement for serine and glycine.
And so there's a kind of maybe a virtuous circle here where increased
ROS drives an even further response to the
serine/glycine-free diet.
So I've told you all the good part here.
We do see this effect in many cancer cells, but not all.
And it's very clear that not all tumors respond to this serine/glycine
depletion approach. And this is just illustrated here by two
genetically engineered models of lung cancer.
Here we're looking at the RAS LKB1-driven lung cancers, and you can see
very nicely the survival benefit of putting these mice onto
a serine/glycine-free diet. But if we take more or
less the same tumor model, but we substitute deletion of
p53 for LKB, here in this RAS p53
lung cancer model, there's absolutely no impact of the serine/glycine-free
diet. And we see the same in the RAS p53-driven
pancreas cancers. So why do not all
cancers respond? Well, another way of asking that
is how do these cancer cells become independent of exogenous serine and
glycine? And one obvious way, which I've already alluded to, is that cells can make
their own serine and glycine. So we can, in many
tumors, we see an increase in the pathway here, the de novo
pathway of serine synthesis, particularly increase in expression of
this first rate-limiting step driven by the enzyme
PHGDH. So we see often that many tumor
cells increase the expression of the de novo serine
synthesis pathway and become less dependent on exogenous
serine. And you can see that here, for example, in a breast cancer
cell line that has an amplified, serine synthesis pathway.
If we take serine and glycine away from these cells, they really don't care.
They're completely indifferent.
They're relying very heavily on this de novo
pathway. This was first described by Rich
Crobimato and
David Sabatini and Matt Vander Heiden many years ago when we first started in
these experiments.
So,
if you go back now and just look in cBioPortal, you see that in fact, many
tumors, many different types of tumors, at least a proportion of the tumors show
evidence of amplification of this serine synthesis pathway.
So it does seem to be a common event for tumor cells to
ramp up their own ability to make serine and glycine.
And so in these cases, obviously, serine
starvation doesn't have any effect.
And the answer there clearly would be, let's use an inhibitor
of this serine synthesis pathway.
So an inhibitor of this PHGDH enzyme, these inhibitors
are available. So Milene, while she was in the lab, thought she'd
try this approach. So she used a cell line that was
resistant to exogenous serine depletion.
We're looking at here are organoids grown from these tumors.
These are now APC RAS-driven colon tumors.
Putting on the inhibitor really doesn't stop their growth.
Taking away serine and glycine has no effect.
But together, you can see you can very profoundly inhibit the growth of these
tumor cells and also the tumors
in mice by using this combination diet.
Julia, since then, has been trying to expand on this and think about are there
other ways in which we can find
genes that may be particularly important in these
serine/glycine-resistant cell lines.
And she just did a CRISPR dropout screen in one of these particular cell
lines,
and looked to see which genes became
conditionally important under conditions of serine/glycine
depletion. So we think the screen worked because we got all
three components of the serine synthesis pathway, which of course you would
expect. We also picked up numerous mitochondrial
transporters. They were significantly enriched, a whole list of them,
suggesting-- oh, we can just see that, an example of one of them
here. This is the folate transporter.
You can see that under normal conditions, serine/glycine fed conditions,
taking away this folate transporter really doesn't
have any effect on the cell growth.
But if we take away the serine and glycine and knock down
expression of this folate transporter, the cells can't grow at
all. They also can't migrate, which is interesting, I think,
because obviously growth and migration, different things.
And again, the tumors, which themselves are resistant to
serine/glycine depleted diets, become
sensitive once they've lost expression of this folate
transporter. And this really is very
similar to work that was published by Lou Cantley, showing that
sort of an intact mitochondrial folate cycle
was important for cells. Interestingly, these cells actually
become glycine auxotrophs, not serine auxotrophs.
So there is some argument that potentially,
combining glycine starvation and mitochondrial
one-carbon cycle inhibitors may be another interesting therapeutic
approach for these types of tumors, and one that we haven't explored
yet experimentally.
But other than increasing de novo serine synthesis, are there other
ways in which cells can become independent of dietary serine and
glycine? And another obvious candidate here is for
the tumor cells to access serine from their
surrounding
stromal cells, the normal stroma cells in the
tumor. And Alec Kimmelman and Robert Barn had a
lovely paper showing that in fact, neurons can release serine to
support pancreatic cancers.And
Yong-Hwan in my lab has been looking at the potential impact of
adipocytes. So we know that there are very important
adipocyte tumor interactions. And what he found was that, in
fact, if you take adipocytes and you starve them of serine and glycine, they
very efficiently upregulate their own de novo serine synthesis
pathway to the extent that they can provide their own serine and
excrete serine. They make enough serine to excrete it into the medium and
glycine. And therefore, not surprisingly, if we take adipocyte
condition medium and grow-- these are now cells that are sensitive to
exogenous serine and glycine, we can rescue
their growth under serine and glycine starvation.
And that rescue depends on the serine synthesis
pathway activity in the adipocytes, because if we make condition
medium from adipocytes that have been given a PHGDH
inhibitor, this doesn't work.
These are very preliminary experiments, but if we now look at
circulating levels of serine and glycine, we can see that if we
deplete adipocytes of their ability to make serine, so if
we use an adipocyte specific PHGDH knockout and
combine this with a serine glycine free diet, we can see that we can
lower the circulating levels of serine and glycine, suggesting
that circulating serine and glycine, to some degree, comes from
adipocytes. And our question now is, is this actually
important for tumor and supporting tumor, and is this more
evident under conditions of obesity, where simplistically there are more
adipocytes? So is it possible that under conditions of obesity,
there's more availability of serine that's derived from the adipocytes?
So that's all fine and dandy. We can think about many experiments
that we can do using serine depletion or
inhibition of serine synthesis in
tumor therapies. But the obvious question then becomes, does this
actually result in any unwanted toxicities?
We're obviously focused on the effect of these combinations on the
tumor cells, but does it have any effect on the normal cells
in the body?
And going back to Mylene's
work, where she uses combinations of serine depleted
diets and inhibitors of the serine synthesis pathway,
we did notice that that did result in weight
loss in the mice that had to be managed quite carefully by
toggling the amount of the inhibitor.
It was very easily rescued, and it didn't seem to correlate with
any clear
damage of any organs or clear abnormalities in the mice.
The mice recovered from this very quickly.
You can see here that we didn't see any overt damage to the
brain, to the liver, or to the kidney.
As far as we could tell, at least these were short term assays over weeks.
The mice were perfectly fine, and if they did lose weight, they recovered that very
quickly when we took away the inhibitor or fed them again with
serine and glycine. However, to be fair, there have been a few
studies to show that, in fact, serine and glycine depletion does have an
impact on normal physiology. There's this very nice paper from Christian
Metallo showing that long-term serine and glycine
depletion in mice, and now we're talking about months to a year,
can lead to peripheral neuropathy.
So these mice stop feeling so much in their paws.
You can put them on a hot plate, and they don't jump up and down so much.
And there are many studies showing the importance of serine
in T cell responses. We have tried to look at
this, not very extensively, I'll admit, and as far as we could
tell, we were not able to see any changes in T cell
infiltration in the tumors from mice that had been fed on a
serine glycine free diet compared to mice fed on a full
diet. But I think that we have to accept that it is very
likely, and Josh has done some beautiful work here, that
serine and the products of the serine pathway formate and
the whole folate cycle will, to some degree,
impede T cell responses. So I think this is a caveat that we
really need to think about.
However, we've also been looking at the response to
serine and glycine, but in a different context.
So I mentioned that sometimes when we put mice on a serine glycine
free diet, they lose weight, particularly if we combine that with a
PHGDH inhibitor. But even just the mice that are normally on
the diet do lose a little body weight.
You can see that here, I hope, in the orange line.
That happens initially when the mice go on the diet, and that does stabilize, so
the body weight doesn't continue to drop, and the mice
are fine. They're perfectly healthy.
They just always remain slightly lighter, and the reason that they're lighter is
that they have less fat,
both subcutaneous and visceral. And you can see that the
adipocytes in that fat are smaller when the mice are fed on a
serine glycine free diet.
And so our question became, does this reduction in body weight
impact the rate of cachexia? So,
this is a sort of a slightly alternative approach
to thinking about this problem. But, as you all know, of
course, cachexia is that debilitating weight loss,
unwanted weight loss that's seen in many cancer
types and is really a particularly big problem in
that it limits life expectancy, it
limits treatment option, and it's very poorly
understood. And there's a
very nice consortium led by Eileen
White looking into this particular problem.So
our initial expectation, I guess, it was that if you
feed mice on a serine/glycine-free diet and they're lighter, they may be
less able to cope with tumors that induce cachexia.
And you can see here that one of these tumor types, the K-RAS/LKB1
lung model,
we had exactly the opposite response.
In fact, the mice that were on the serine/glycine-free diet showed less weight
loss than the mice that were on the control diet.
Now, the problem with this particular experiment is something that I showed you
earlier, which is in this model, the serine/glycine-free diet actually delays
tumor genesis.
So the question here becomes, is serine/glycine starvation actually doing something
to cachexia, or is it just delaying tumor progression, and so naturally
the cachexic response comes later?
So in order to answer that, we turn to the other model
that I showed you earlier, the K-RAS/p53 cancer model, where we
don't see an impact on tumor progression, tumor growth.
And again, here we see that while the mice on the diet
are slightly lighter, they don't lose weight the way that the mice on the
control diet do. This is looking at visceral WAT,
subcutaneous WAT. And here's an orthotopic pancreatic model.
This is a lung cancer, this is a pancreas cancer, and again, we see
exactly the same thing. Obviously, this is a work in progress.
But initially what we can say is that serine/glycine
starvation somehow limits the induction of the
cachectic and inflammatory markers
that have been associated with this body weight loss
under normal conditions. So here you can see that
GDF15, which is strongly associated with cachexia, is not so
strongly increased in the mice on the serine/glycine-free diet.
Similarly here with plasma IL6, which again has been
related to cachexia. And I know you can't see
this, but basically what we're doing here is we're asking in our two models
what's down compared to mice on normal chow.
And what you see here down at the bottom are many inflammatory markers
that are less highly expressed in the circulation of
mice that are on a serine/glycine-free diet.
So initially at least, the working hypothesis is that serine/glycine
limitation can somehow provoke a healthier systemic
response. There's less inflammation, and somehow that provides
some protection from cachexia. And what we're trying to do now is
answer the question, if we look at people who are very lean,
below normal BMI, do they also show this
delay or somehow protection from cachexia that may be
unrelated to the actual progression of their tumor?
Oops, going backwards. Okay, so just a final word
then. I think we, at least in the lab, are convinced that
we should be pursuing something that is called precision
nutrition. And just like every other precision
medicine,
that depends on a much better mechanistic understanding
of what the nutritional vulnerabilities of different cancers might be.
And can we really harness that mechanistic understanding to
devise clever new ways to treat these tumors?
And that's all that's left to me then is to thank my lab.
I've mentioned the people who did the work, people who are still in the lab, people
who have left the lab and gone on to bigger and better things, and all of our
wonderful collaborators. And I think I have a few
minutes left in case there are any questions. So thank you for listening.
Mark.
That was very nice. I'm not sure if this
is on. I think so.
That was very nice. I was really intrigued by the
GDF15 data because I think that's a really
important area of research
with cachexia. The adipose tissue looked really
good.
Yes, yes.
And
obesity is a risk factor for
some of these cancers, pancreatic cancer, for example.
So have you ever put the animals on a high-fat diet
to make them obese and then switched them
to the serine-free? Because I actually
think you'll see
even more profound effects because obesity
itself increases GDF15.
Right.
Have you ever done-
Yes. No, we haven't done that. We haven't done.
What we have done is we've taken mice with the
adipocyte-specific PHGDH knockout and put
them on an obesogenic diet, and they also
gain weight,
albeit not as quite as fast as the normal mice.
But we haven't done the experiment you suggest.
That's a good experiment, and we could try that.
I'll definitely-
Easy experiment.
Yes.
And the other thing is just simply, what's the mechanism
by which when you take these amino acids out of the
diet, they have this effect on the
adipose tissue landscape?
I have no idea. We don't even know whether it's a
response to the adipocytes themselves or whether
it's a response to another cell type that's then impacting the
adipocytes.
Yeah. Because I'm sure if you did an F480 stain-
Mm-hmm.
You'll see-
Less
... weightless, and that's why the IL6 is there.
Yes.
So those experiments are ongoing right now. Yes.
Hi, Karen. Great talk.
Thank you.
Following Mark's question, I was just wondering if you have looked at
muscle mass, lean body mass, how that may influence the-
We didn't see any effect on muscle massBut to be
honest,
in most of our models, we see a relatively small
impact on muscle mass in our cachectic mice.
So the principal effect that we see is on adipose
tissue. So I don't know if we switch to a model where there was a much more
profound effect on muscle, whether we would see something there.
Thank you.
Mark Malkin, Neuro-Oncology, Cleveland Clinic.
Two questions. I'll take them one at a time if we have time.
My patients often ask me if there's anything they can do to modify their diet,
specifically by eliminating sugar from their
diet. And I tell them, "No, even if you
eliminate sugar from the diet, your cancer cells will make serine and glycine, and
they'll bypass it.
And your normal tissues need glucose for all sorts of healthy reasons."
Correct advice?
I think we don't know enough yet to give advice.
We
talk a lot to patients, and this is
the obvious question, and this is why I'm kind of trying to fly the
flag that we need the mechanistic understanding.
I would hesitate to give advice to any cancer patient on the
basis of some mouse experiments. I think we need properly constructed
trials. But I think that there is potential, and we should be
pursuing these so that we can tell our patients with
confidence what they should and shouldn't be doing.
I have to say, I think that precision is the right word.
I think it's going to be different for different tumors, different therapies-
Mm
... different patients.
Mm.
So there's not going to be a one-size-fits-all, you shouldn't eat sugar, you
shouldn't eat serine. I think it's going to be really very context dependent.
Right. The IDH wild type tumors may behave differently than-
Exactly. Yes
... IDH mutated. Right. And the second question is,
glioblastoma patients don't develop cancer-associated cachexia
per se.
But because many of them are dependent on dexamethasone to manage vasogenic
edema,
they do develop muscle wasting-
Mm-hmm
... or the previous question. I'd be interested to know
what these experiments would show in a
xenograft model of glioblastoma.
Yes. That's nothing that we've done, but that would be interesting.
Josh?
Oh. Sorry.
Very quickly. I may have missed this, but where
do estrogen receptor-positive breast cancers fall in the serine
metabolism?
Oh, God. I don't know the answer to that. I'm so sorry.
I
guess we could find out, but I think most of the
breast cancers that were shown to amplify the serine synthesis
pathway were triple-negative breast cancers.
And the few that we have that we
use in the lab are all triple-negative breast cancers.
At least in our work, looking at serine levels, we find that
higher serine levels correlate with aggressiveness in our breast cancer patients.
Right. Well, higher circulating serine levels.
Exactly. Plasma.
Yeah. That's possible, yes.
Okay.
Because you would imagine that would be able to feed the tumor.
Exactly.
Mm. Thank you.
Josh.
A good follow-up on the last question.
So I noticed that in addition to the substantial number with some
form of amplification in the serine synthesis pathway, there's also a smaller
set with some sort of deletion.
Yes, there is.
If whoever had studied those.
No, we haven't. It does beg the question.
And Alex's paper showed really nicely that in many
human pancreas cancers, there's
a deletion of serine synthesis pathway, which is where they got to the
innovation.
I think Sarah Maria Fent had quite a nice paper that
described how loss of de novo serine synthesis could be
advantageous to cancers. It was quite convoluted and
complicated, but you have to accept that in some
cancers, there is a selection for loss of de novo serine synthesis.
And obviously, in those tumors, you would expect them to
be super sensitive to dietary serine and glycine.
And in fact, in Fyte, our little company, we
have been trying to treat patients, and we've selected them
on the basis that they have loss of expression of one of the serine synthesis
pathway enzymes. So that would be an example of where
you would want to select your patients in order to
suggest some degree of dietary modification.
All right. Great. Thank you.
Okay. I think I can have time for two very quick-- I'm the
chairperson, so I mustn't be naughty.
Yeah. Very quick question.
So I have a question regarding the body weight, in terms of the serine
depletion diet. And so while you did
not observe any weight loss for the
model that did not respond to the treatment or the
diet, but you did observe a weight loss in the
beginning, for those responding.
Yeah. No. They all show weight loss.
Even a normal mouse, if you put it on a serine glycine free diet, there's a slight
weight loss at the beginning. So that's not specific to any tumor type.
So it should not be related to any response?
No, I don't think so. I think that's just what happens in mice when you put them on
a serine glycine free diet.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi. Great talk. I'm Valerie Gunchuk. I'm a PhD student at Vanderbilt.
And I think you mentioned that adipocytes can
excrete serine or glycine. Is that
subcutaneous or visceral fat?
It's in our tissue culture plate.
Okay.
Because that was with pancreatic cancer, I think that was part of the slide that-
Well, I think... No. Yes. We use that to support the pancreatic
cancer cells. The data that we have, I guess, to suggest
thatadipocytes in the body support
serine synthesis is that we see a drop in circulating
serine if we deplete serine synthesis in
adipocytes. So if we have a mouse where the adipocytes can't make
serine, they have slightly less circulating serine.
I see. Interesting. Because I have
done analysis of subcutaneous fat and visceral fat
survival in pancreatic cancer, and actually patients with more
subcutaneous fat live much longer than those with less.
Oh, interesting.
Thank you.
Okay. We must move on. So thank you for all those questions.
That was wonderful. And so our next speaker is Mark Fabreo
from Monash University, and he's going to tell us about physical activity as
a therapeutic for cancer treatment.
I just remembered that there are questions online, but we don't have time.
Sorry to everyone online.
I just want to start by thanking Karen for inviting me to this
symposium.
So
in our lab, I'm
actually a trained exercise physiologist, and I've been
working on the interaction between physical activity and
disease for a number of years. And you can see
here that this review just came out a couple of weeks ago,
that
now we know there are several diseases,
which we call lifestyle diseases, where
exercise has a protective effect.
And you can see here that one of those
diseases is cancer.
And
much of the
reason why we think
exercise is beneficial for
treatment of cancer as an adjunct therapy
is due to
the immune system being
ramped up. But
I think by the end of this, you'll see that it's probably a little
more complicated than that. And,
so we think that
exercise can be a preventative treatment for these non-contagious
diseases. But we have a real bias in
the lab, given that we coined the term
myokine or muscle-secreting factor, that
there is a very complex inter-organ
communication
in cancer,
but also in cancer and exercise and cancer and diet.
And you can see from this review that was
really spearheaded by Charlie,
it's very complex, this
disease, as we know,
and it's an interplay between genetics and
lifestyle. And one of the things
that we know is that lifelong
exercisers can be protected
from some of these diseases, including cancer.
Now,
as I said, in our lab, we study this, and this was a nice
review that was spearheaded by
David Nash, who's now actually in San Diego.
He's in Reuben's lab at the Salk. And you can see
that
it's not just the immune
system here. It's not just the trafficking of immune
cells and the metabolism of the immune cells and
the function of the immune cells, but there's a little bit of
metabolic remodeling. And as I said, there are exercise-derived
factors
that can mitigate some of these protective effects, and
that's what I'm going to focus on today.
So,
there are about
seven to 10 cancers where the
epidemiological data suggests that exercise
protects. And two of these cancers
where there's a lot of evidence is colorectal
cancer
and breast cancer. And so,
we chose to study breast cancer
initially.
And so we did this experiment.
We
used the
41.2 cell model of breast cancer,
and we injected the mice with the
tumors. And then when we had a palpable tumor,
we had them in cages already where
they had a running wheel,
and the running wheel was locked.
And then when we palpated the tumors,
we unlocked half the wheels and let the
animals voluntarily run. Now,
mice love to run way more than humans,
for a couple of reasons, really. Number one is, for starters, we
do all our experiments wrong because we do them at
thermoneutrality for
man
or human at rest, and we should be doing
thermoneutrality for mice, which is 30 degrees.
So one of the reasons they run a little bit, we think, is because they're
cold,
but they do run a lot, as you can see here.
They run about
seven Ks a night,
and they like it, as you can
see.So we just wanted to see at the
end of the
experiment what happened to the tumors, and you can see that
tumor volume, tumor weight,
is improved by
these mice that run. Now, remember, the cage enrichment is
the same. Everything's the same. The only thing is
the mice that like to run
in the locked wheel can't run. Okay. And we monitor it all.
So that's the only difference. So it is the running that's doing this.
And when we looked at metastases,
because we had an mCherry label and we had luciferin,
you can see that there's
way
fewer metastases.
And one of the things
that you should understand is that
the more you exercise, the better.
And the all-cause mortality,
I'm not saying you should go out and do an Ironman every day
because really extreme exercise is not great
because
you can get myocardial problems.
I know this.
Anyway,
but you can see from this experiment
that we actually
segregated the data
on the animals that like to run a lot
and the animals that only ran a little.
And the metastatic burden
was really stark
in the animals that ran over six and a half Ks a
day compared to those that ran under,
and the metastatic-free survival was
improved. Right? So
if you're a mouse
and you get breast cancer,
run,
is the bottom line. And the mechanism seems
to be in
the EMT. So all of the proteins
that are associated with
EMT
are suppressed by exercise.
Now, as I said,
there are many papers, one by the late Pernilla Hollmann from
Copenhagen and another by Dafna Bar-Sagi, who's actually
chairing a session two doors down at the moment.
And in these experiments, both in,
I think Pernilla did
a lung tumor model and
Dafna did pancreatic cancer. It really was
the way that the exercise was modifying the
immune system. And as I showed you from our reviews and
what we know,
most of the effects with exercise are through the immune
system. So,
it made sense that we looked at the immune system first, and we
did this work with a real immunologist,
Axel Kallies, who's
a very reputable immunologist. And the results were really
quite disappointing, to be honest.
There really wasn't anything
remarkable in the immune system. Now,
remember, this is one model of tumor, one model of cancer.
So that's the caveat here. We're doing some more models.
But we really didn't see anything in T cells
or B cells. The number of exhausted T cells
in the tumor, if anything, went up with exercise.
It was pretty disappointing.
And so we started examining
alternate mechanisms, and as I said, my bias
is on
tissue crosstalk and
the transfer
of myokines from muscle to other areas.
And
we published a few reviews
showing that the muscle really can secrete
many
proteins that affect
peripheral organs. But it's not just the muscle that
secretes
these proteins during exercise.
Now the term is exokine rather than myokine, because
myokine only limits what's released from muscle.
But you can see here in this review that we had published a few years ago that
Lisa Chow spearheaded,
there are so many
of these proteins that can get released from
all sorts of tissues during exercise.
One of the problems, however, when you're looking at the plasma
proteome, is that albumin is very sticky.
So it's hard technically.
So what we started doing about a decade ago is
looking at what's in
extracellular vesicles or small extracellular
vesicles
during exercise. And this is just a schematic
from Nimna Pereira's review showing
what's in
a vesicle and how it can get released, et cetera.
And so
about 10 years ago, Martin Whitham, when he was a
postdoc in the lab, published this paper in "Cell
Met,"
which really showed that
these extracellular vesicles
contain a lot of cool stuffSo this is an experiment we
did
with our collaborators in Copenhagen, and we just had people
exercise on a bike, and then we isolated
EVs. One thing you can see here is that during exercise, the actual
number of particles doubles. Right?
And you can see them by cryo-EM that they're
various sizes. We really isolate using small
EVs. And we were able to isolate over 5,000
proteins in these EVs. And depending on what
statistics you ran,
if you ran very, very annotated strict
statistics, you got 322 of these
proteins that were different between rest and exercise, and
over 1,000 if you did non-annotated statistics.
So we recently did another study with John Hawley and Nolan Hoffman, where
we basically did the same thing.
This is just showing you that it's important to
try and get as pure a vesicle
population as you can.
And then Gui did this experiment, which was
pretty illuminating.
He took
two cell lines, cancer cell lines,
and he just treated them with
either PBS
or he took an EV fraction and
a non-EV fraction from a sedentary
mouse and an exercise mouse.
And what you can see very clearly there
is that
the EV fraction from the exercise
mouse had a profound effect on
cell proliferation and cell viability.
And it's not an artifact of the EV
because
the sedentary EV didn't really have much of an effect.
And it's not a generalized exercise effect either,
because if anything, the non-EV fraction from the
same animals made the proliferation
worse. So it's something intrinsic in the
EV.
And so we did the following experiment with our collaborators,
at La Trobe University, Suresh's group.
So we decided to run exactly the same
experiment as we ran in our lab
when we exercised the animals. But this time what we
did is we did the exact same model,
but instead of exercising the animals,
we purified EVs from previously
exercised animals and tail-injected
those into recipient animals. So now the animals
aren't exercising, they're just getting EVs
from the exercised animals. And we asked the question: Do
the EVs mitigate some of the effects that we saw when
we gave them the running wheels? And the answer was yes.
Because you can see here, the animals that got the
exercise EVs, and so they got an EV
injection every second day for the period
that they were in the running wheel in the first experiment.
And you could see clearly here that tumor volume
was
improved and not at all if they got sedentary
EVs.
So there's something intrinsic
in the exercise EV that's slowing down
tumor progression. And if you looked at metastases,
same thing.
The
exercise EVs were having this effect
similar to exercise itself.
And remember, these experiments were done even in two separate vivers.
So we're pretty confident with the data.
Now, what's the mechanism? So, as I said, it didn't seem to
be the immune system. So what we did is
we're
a bit biased towards proteomics in our lab.
So what we did is we ran a proteomic screen on the
sedentary EVs and the exercise EVs.
And what we did is we took the data
from-- we filtered the data looking at proteins that were
more than twofold higher when you compared the
exercise EV to the sedentary EV. And then we ran
them through three tumor databases.
And we came up with two candidate
proteins, as you can see. These are
MTSS1
and NME2.
Now, what are these proteins? Well,
MTSS1 is a multifunctional scaffold
protein that suppresses tumor progression and
metastases. And NME2
inhibits metastases in breast cancer, and
a decrease in expression in humans correlates with a greater
metastatic burden. Right? So the first thing we did is we went and
checked mouse plasma and human plasma, making sure that our
proteomics was accurate. We went old school and
for the young people in the audience, that's a Western blot.
So we did some Western blotting to prove that.
And it was in the human plasma. We're actually now doing a
breast cancer population.
That's the next stepAnd what we did
next is we overexpressed these
proteins in 41.2
cells, and we did a cell migration
scratch assay,
and the migration was inhibited.
So these proteins are having that effect.
And
we then
engineered these proteins
into HEK cells,
and we stimulated HEK cells with a calcium
ionophore to mimic exercise. We
purified the EVs from the supernatant, and then
we put those onto the cancer cells, and
we got the same result.
So
what we think is,
in addition to exercise
mobilizing immune cells, that muscle
releases anti-metastatic
proteins within vesicles
that modulate mainly, from our data, the
EMT, which plays a role in metastatic
cancer.
So what we want to do, ultimately,
is
if a woman
is diagnosed with breast cancer
and they can exercise,
we want to harness their EVs and store them,
so that if they undergo
chemotherapy
and they're unable to exercise because of
fatigue, et cetera, we can then put those EVs back in
to the patients as an adjuvant therapy,
somewhat analogous to CAR T-cell therapy.
So that's our
plan in the future, is to translate this,
but it remains to be seen. So with that,
I'd
sort of thank the people that did the work and
our collaborators, and thanks for your attention.
I'm happy to answer any questions.
So that was very interesting. As a good skiing buddy of mine who's
a geriatrician in Oxford says, "The best treatment for all his
patients that beats all drug therapy is exercise." So I think this
fits in very well. But what I'm interested in is, you alluded to this, was
extreme exercise. So,
there's emerging data, I think particularly in some neurological degenerative
disease, motor neuron disease, that some of these people have
quite a sporting background, and I was wondering if you could
comment on that. And also on those extreme sportsmen,
ultramarathon runners, and so on.
What's in their genetics that allows them to achieve that sort
of level of exercise without presumably falling in
that group?
So with the
motor neuron disease,
there seems to be an association
between lifelong exercises and
that disease. I might add, actually, that exercise is not good for
every cancer.
There's
one cancer where
exercise is actually
shown to be
bad or-- and that is, of course,
melanoma, because when you exercise a lot, you're out in the sun, basically.
That you can argue the toss. With the ALS, we really don't
know the mechanism.
There is some suggestion
that it could be related to lactate,
but I don't know.
With the extreme exercise, the major
issue-- I don't think cancer is an issue.
The major issue you have there is
cardiac problems. Because
there are a lot of people that
are
extreme, like Ironman triathletes, and
can get
ventricular tachycardia or atrial fibrillation,
and that's related to
micro contusions in their myocardium when they're exercising really
hard for a really long time. For cancer, I don't
think
it's really an issue, and I don't think that
it contributes to cachexia either, because I'm starting to think the
cachexia is all related to GDF15, and if you
exercise, that goes down.
Phil Amerang from Boston.
I didn't see any assay for cortisol.
I would think extreme exercise would cause a burst of cortisol, and
that would have an effect.
We
have published on that, that
we did a PYMT model with exercise.
The cortisol change is very
transient, and the cortisol
didn't seem to have a remarkable effect in our models.
Mark, can you get to this?
Hi.
Sorry.
Hi. I have two quick questions. I'm Jun from National Taiwan
University Cancer Center. The first one is, can you comment on
the effects of, for example, different types of
exercise? For example, if the mice is running
wheels or they are running treadmills-
Mm-hmm.
... is there any difference in the effects
of cancer growth? And the second part is, you didn't
mention a lot about weight loss.
Yeah.
Does that have certain effects in this model as well? Thank you.
Okay. So they're both good questions.
The first question is that if you're doing
mouse experiments, I would not force wheel
run the animals because
then cortisol does go up, as do other stress hormones.
So if we
treadmill run our mice,
they don't get the same benefit.
They get a benefit, but they don't get the same benefit as voluntary
exercise. That's number one. Number two is
that the therapeutics
for the clinicians out there, the therapeutics that seem
to be in place is to do a
combination of endurance exercise, like ride a
bike for 30 minutes, and then resistance exercise, because
maintaining muscle integrity and mass is really important.
I forgot the second question.
Sorry.
No time.
No time. I don't have time to answer the... I forgot your second question.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Very nice. Interesting. Adriana Albini from Cancer Institute in
Italy.
We've done studies on breast cancer patients,
neoadjuvant combination, so the physical
activity moderate, so that also patients could do it,
did decrease inflammation. So
I also was wondering, what is the possibility
to do
combining during
therapeutic
effect and
how we can implement that? Because one of the problems is
also, that at least in Italy, you cannot
prescribe it, so it's basically on a volunteer basis, and I
think that now efficacy is from you and other
clinical studies very demonstrated.
Okay. So with the
inflammation and the immunity, all of the work we've
done over the last
25, 30 years suggests that exercise is actually
anti-inflammatory.
Yeah.
So we published a paper years ago where
we actually gave people low-dose endotoxin.
We could only do this in Copenhagen 25 years ago.
But we gave low-dose endotoxin to people, and we exercised them all night,
and
you didn't get a TNF response if you exercise.
So exercise is anti-inflammatory, and it primes the immune system.
We didn't see that in the mice, but as I said, that was one
experiment. I think
the
AACR now,
it's in their guidelines to have exercise as adjuvant
therapy. So I think
personally, of course, I'm going to say
if you can exercise and you have cancer, you
should.
Mark, can I just go to one question online? Sorry, guys.
Which is, we can reduce the dimensionality of various
forms of exercise to heart rate. What heart rate or heart rate
zone is required to achieve this?
That's a very good question, and I don't have the answer.
We haven't done
the experiments where we
compare
brisk walking to bicycle exercise.
So I really would be just hand-waving to answer that,
so apologies.
Okay, so we've got two more questions very quickly, please.
Is it possible that there's a positive feedback loop so that
you exercise, you generate EVs,
that reduces cancer cell proliferation, migration,
your endurance goes up so you can exercise more,
et cetera?
Does that possibility exist?
Certainly. And the other thing that I think is really
important in this whole process, at least in some of the
patients
that have been done, is
exercise is very good for mood and very good
as an anti-depression. And we actually know the mechanisms of that, too.
Some work out of Bruce Spiegelman's lab
had one mechanism of this. We've
been doing a lot of work on this ourselves.
So,
if you reduce--
The patients get together, and they exercise together.
They have a sense of community. They look forward to it.
Their
mood and their outlook is better. So then stress
hormones go down. So there is, I think, a feedback loop.
I think that's an important point.
So my question is,
as you rightly mentioned that
exercise really helps in secreting EVs.
So that depends on the intensity of exercise.
It also, in parallel, shapes different types of
hormones that get secreted during the process.
So do you think there is an alternate way or alternate mechanism that
is helping these molecules being secreted from muscle
that is also induced by hormones as well?
Yes. Actually, the paper that I showed
from
Penelope Hauman's work in cell metabolism,
the
NK cells were mobilized
by
epinephrine and IL-6. So the
answer to your question is yes.
Really sorry, but-
City of Hull
... we're going to have to move on. So Mark, thank you for a fabulous talk.
And
you can ask him more questions later.
So,
last but not least, we have Minyang Song from Harvard School of
Public Health who's going to tell us about harnessing diet microbiome
interactions for cancer prevention.
Thank you, Karen, for the kind introduction, and I want to thank the committee
for the invitation. So
following two wonderful talks, we are going to switch gears
and look at the epidemiology literature regarding diet
microbiome interaction in cancer.
So among all cancers, colorectal cancer, CRC, is
probably the cancer that is most strongly associated with diet
and lifestyle, and also probably has the best evidence.
So this is a report summary from the World Cancer Research Fund and
the American Institute for Cancer Research.
So we can see here,
there is convincing evidence that obesity increase
colon cancer risk, whereas physical activity reduce cancer risk.
And among individual dietary factors, processed meat,
alcohol, and red meat have been shown to increase
colon cancer, whereas dairy products,
calcium, whole grains, and fiber have been shown to be beneficial
for colon cancer incidence. And we can also see a lot
more individual dietary factors are in the category of
limited evidence,
because of the inconsistent
results from the epidemiologic findings.
So we know there is very close relationship between diet and
microbiome. So diet is a major determinant of the
microbiome, whereas microbiome is also
involved in the absorption and metabolism of numerous
dietary factors. And we know both diet and microbiome
are critical for our host metabolism and immunity.
Therefore, we propose this triad model,
and indicated that it is the interplay between diet,
microbiome, and host factor that together determines an
individual's cancer risk.
So in terms of the relationship with the microbiome, colon cancer
is also probably the cancer that has the best evidence.
So the existing literature suggests that
microbiome can promote or influence cancer
development by changing the balance of host cell
proliferation and death, and by influencing the immune and metabolic
systems. And for individual microbes,
certain microbes have been shown to be enriched in
colon cancer, including Fusobacterium nucleatum and
Bacteroides fragilis, and also pks+ E.
coli. Whereas short chain fatty acid-producing
bacteria have been shown to be depleted in colon
cancer. However, I just want to make a note that all these
findings from the epidemiological literature are based on retrospective
studies. In other words,
the studies collected samples from patients with established
cancer and compared that to the samples from healthy
controls. So the cause versus consequence
distinction is
difficult to establish from these studies.
And in terms of how microbiome may mediate diet-colon cancer
relationship, this figure is from a review that we
wrote a few years ago, and we identified four groups
of bacteria that can potentially mediate the diet CRC
relationship. These include short chain fatty acid-producing
bacteria,
hydrogen sulfide-producing bacteria, and bacteria
that can produce secondary bile acid, as well as the
TMAO-producing bacteria from choline.
So these microbial metabolites can influence
various metabolic and immune pathways that can
further influence cancer development.
So based on the existing evidence, we believe that
by accounting for the interplay between diet and the microbiome, we
can better understand how diet may be
implicated in colon cancer development, and also
hopefully by producing more robust epidemiologic evidence.
Like I showed earlier, a lot of the individual dietary factors have shown
inconsistent results across studies.
So one of the reasons may be due to the lack of the consideration of
the microbial
variations across individuals. And ultimately, the goal
is to develop tailored preventive strategies, the
so-called precision nutrition.
So to address this question, we need
large-scale population-based studies that have
collected detailed dietary data and also
microbiome information. So the Nurses Health Study 2
provides a really unique resource for that.
So the Nurses Health Study 2 was established in 1989
at our school by enrolling over 100,000
participants. And as you can see, over the past nearly four
decades, we have collected very detailed dietary information
through repeated
food frequency questionnaires. We have also collected other
lifestyle and medication information as well as
biospecimens.
So
in late 2019, we initiated the Microbiome Among
Nurses study, the MicroeN study, with the goal of
establishing a baseline microbiome
resource toFurther to
prospectively study the role of the microbiome in disease
development. And our target was to
collect the samples from 20,000 women who
were still under active follow-up in the Nurses Health
Study Too. And now we have nearly accomplished
that
target.
So the study design and methodology of this collection has already been
published.
We also included very detailed all the materials that we have
used in this collection.
And
very unique feature of colon cancer is,
it has very well characterized natural history.
And we know most colon cancer arise from
the precursors, the so-called polyps.
And there are two major types of polyps, including adenoma and
serrated polyp, as they have very distinct molecular and
histological features. And
because of this prolonged
period of colon cancer development,
we can better characterize how specifically
microbiome changes along this pathway and
what is the causality, what is the causal effect of the
microbiome in this process.
So
here,
in this talk, I'm going to show some data that we
have
collected to address three major research questions using the
microN data. The first is how do the microbiome
changes along the polyp to CRC pathway?
As I indicated earlier,
there is a very long latency period for colon cancer
development. And because of the microbiome actually lives in
our gut, the cancer itself can induce very
substantial biochemical changes and also impose selective
pressure on the microbiome. So this makes
it very difficult to disentangle whether the microbiome
changes are a cause or consequence of cancer development.
So we do need data, like prospective data,
collected along this polyp to CRC sequence.
And the second question is, can that recapitulate the
CRC-associated microbial alterations?
And finally, what are the role of the individual dietary factors in
modulating the microbiome and the colon cancer?
So to address the first question,
we leveraged the well-characterized natural history of colon
cancer and conducted two case-control studies
by using the samples collected at different time points on
this
pathway. So the first study is a case-control
study of incident polyps, where we collected stool
samples from patients who haven't developed polyps.
So this is a very early stage of this
colon cancer development, and we matched with the
endoscopy-matched controls. So the
samples were collected prior to polyp
diagnosis. Another case-control study is for
prevalent polyps. In other words, it's after
polyp removal by colonoscopy. And,
so this can tell us what the microbiome changes look
like after adenoma removal. Do we still see the
similar changes in the patients?
And also we leverage the published studies on colorectal cancer.
Again, as I mentioned earlier, these studies collected samples
post diagnosis of colon cancer from
established colon cancer patients.
So
by comparing the three separate studies, we can see
that the microbiome changes increased substantially
over the polyp to cancer sequence.
So when we look at incident polyps, we can see when we build
the random forest, the prediction model, the accuracy, the
AUC is very poor. It's nearly non-predictive at all.
And when we move on to prevalent polyp, we do see the microbiome
has AUC of 0.67, indicating a modest
distinction between
polyps and controls. And whereas when we move on to
CRC, we see a very strong
predictivity. The microbiome is highly predictive of the
CRC. So this indicates that the microbiome
changes in the very early stage of colon cancer development
is more subtle and also not really
predictive of the outcome.
And then we looked at how the microbial
changes are correlated between different outcomes.
So here we show the
correlation between the microbiome changes in incident polyps
versus the prevalent polyp and the CRC.
We can see there is nearly no correlation at all.
Again, indicating that the changes that occur prior
to polyp development do not really correlate with the
changes that occur much later in the process.
And when we look at microbial abundance as another measure,
instead of just looking at the presence or
absence of the microbes, we now look at the quantitative
abundance of each microbes. We can still say the correlation
is very low,
nearly non-present.
And there is a small, very weak correlation with the
CRC, but the correlation is still very
lowHowever, we do see,
when we look at individual microbes, there are some microbes that are
consistently changed,
like in the incident polyps versus prevalent polyp and the
CRC, so along this diagonal line. So indicates that
there are still some individual microbes that may have
changed in the early stage of colon cancer development.
And also, as I mentioned earlier, there are different molecular pathways
for colon cancer development, with adenoma and serrated
polyps as the two major precursor lesions for these
pathways. And when we look at the microbial profiles between
the two subtypes, we see very different
profiles. So there's
no really consistent changes between the subtypes.
So the first and second column for
both the abundance and the prevalence.
And when we look at a prevalent serrated polyp versus
adenoma, again, we don't really see any consistent
changes between these two subtypes.
So this indicates that distinct microbial changes may
underlie the distinct molecular
subtypes of colorectal cancer.
So when we look at individual microbes along this
polyp-CRC sequence, so this is a summary of the
results that
we generated. We can say in healthy controls, the
microbiome is enriched with healthy microbes,
the microbes that have established benefit, such as
the Faecalibacterium
prausnitzii,
which can produce butyrate. And when we move on to the polyp
stage, we can identify some
microbes that have been associated with colon cancer.
And when we move on to the colon cancer stage, and the
individual microbes that are enriched
are over-represented by the mucosa-associated
microbes such as
Bacteroides fragilis, and also the microbes of
oral origin, such as Fusobacterium nucleatum.
So this indicates a
substantial change along this polyp-CRC sequence.
So to summarize the results from
on the first research question,
we found that microbial changes in the polyp phase
subtle and distinct from those observed in CRC.
So this has important implications for our
understanding about the role of the microbiome in cancer development,
indicating that the so far identified microbes
associated with CRC may not play a critical role in the
early initiation of colon cancer.
So in other words, they may
be more likely to serve as passengers or
promoters rather than driver bacteria.
So the second question we addressed is, can
diet recapitulate the CRC-associated microbial
alterations given the
close relationship between diet and the microbiome?
So we can say that is indeed the case when
we look at the correlation between the microbes
that are found to be enriched in colon cancer or
adenomas, and these microbes tend to have a
positive association with the unhealthy
diet lifestyle factors such as red meat, high BMI,
sugar-sweetened beverage intake.
Whereas the microbes that are depleted in the
cases
tend to be positively associated with the healthy
dietary factors such as fruits, nuts, vegetables,
physical activity. And as you can see in the middle, we included
age as a negative control. Like none of these changes is
associated with age, indicating that the changes are not
just due to CRC itself. It does
recapitulate the overall diet and the lifestyle
patterns that have been associated with CRC.
And we can also see that the correlation pattern is
stronger among cases compared to controls.
So,
we saw similar results when we look at colon cancer
specifically. So we developed a CRC microbial
diet score by using the microbes that have been
associated with CRC as the outcome.
So basically, we want to identify a
combination of food groups that is
associated with the CRC-associated microbes.
And we saw that this new dietary pattern has
a very strong correlation with the established diet,
as you can see here, a positive correlation with Western diet and negative
correlation with prudent, healthy diet.
Indicating that by using the CRC-associated
microbes as the single response variable, we can
identify a dietary pattern that
recapitulates the general healthy versus
unhealthy dietary pattern.
And when we apply this score to our
population-based cohorts, we say this
dietary score has a positive association with colon cancer risk.
This is after adjusting for various risk factors for colon
cancer.
And also, most strikingly, when we separate the colon
cancer into
subtypes according to the presence of the tissue bacteria,
we saw the CRC microbial diet score
showed a much stronger association with colon cancer risk
among for CRCs that have positive
bacteria in the tumor tissue. Again, this indicates
thatCR's diet may indeed
play an important role by modulating the microbiome.
So to summarize the findings from research question two on top of
the first question, so we believe that
diet and lifestyle is really driving the microbial changes
along the
colon cancer development sequence.
So the last question, what are the role of the individual dietary
factors in modulating the microbiome and the CRC?
So for that, today I'm going to focus on a particular dietary
factor, which is coffee drinking.
I'm sure probably most of you have taken some coffee this morning to
cope with the early
session. So when we look at our
cohort data, look at coffee drinking after colon cancer
diagnosis, we saw that coffee drinkers had a
substantially better survival compared to non-coffee drinkers.
So we assessed the coffee drinking after colon cancer diagnosis, and we
see this very strong inverse association, again,
after adjusting for potential confounders.
And when we look at caffeinated versus decaffeinated coffee
separately, we see the association is pretty consistent.
In other words, it indicates that it's not caffeine that is driving
this benefit, probably something else in coffee.
And also remarkably, similar results have been reported in
other cohorts
in very different settings. As you can see here, when compared to
non-drinkers, the heavy coffee
drinkers had a much better survival
among colon cancer patients.
And based on this observational data, we are now conducting a
randomized control trial in collaboration with my colleagues at the
Mass General Cancer Center. So we aim
to enroll 80 patients who have completed a standard
treatment for Stage 1 to 3 colorectal cancer, and the
patients will be randomized to either coffee or placebo
treatment. And for treatment, we use the encapsulated
instant coffee as intervention to help standardize the
treatment. And six grams per day is roughly equivalent to
about three cups of standard coffee.
And the duration is three months. And at baseline and after
intervention,
we are conducting very detailed liver assessment because we
think fatty liver can play an important role in
the potential benefit of coffee among colon
cancer patients because the majority of colon cancer patients
die from liver metastasis.
And also we are collecting other biospecimens.
And in terms of the relationship of coffee with the microbiome,
this is a study that we published last year in collaboration with Dr.
Nicolas Getta from Italy, and we saw a very strong and
a specific impact of coffee on the microbiome.
So first, when we rank all the individual dietary factors
for their relationship with the microbiome, we can see that coffee
clearly stands out as a factor that is most strongly associated
with the microbiome. In other words, by using microbiome,
we can actually very accurately differentiate coffee
drinkers versus non-drinkers.
And when we look at the individual microbes that are associated with coffee,
we see this, identify this Lawsonia bacter, a
lacticus
species that showed a very strong positive correlation with
coffee consumption.
And this is very unique in that for other
dietary factors, when we look at their relationship
with the microbiome, we tend to identify a
group of microbes that showed a modest association.
But in this case, we see a very strong, very specific
association with a particular bacteria.
And we were able to kind of validate this
finding using data across the globe,
regardless what type of coffee people are drinking.
And we also validated the findings using some in vitro
experiment, and we see that coffee can indeed promote the
growth of this specific bacteria in the in vitro
setting. And when we link the diet
and microbiome data to the plasma metabolomics,
we identified a very strong, very specific
metabolomic changes that co-vary
with coffee consumption and also the abundance of this Lawsonia
bacter,
indicating that the interplay between coffee and the microbiome
may have downstream impact on the
host metabolism. So now we are following up these findings to
look at colon cancer patients specifically.
So in the trial that I just presented, we are going to
specifically test the effect of coffee on the microbiome and
how that related to the clinical outcomes.
So in summary,
from the first
investigation, we identified microbiome
changes along the polyp CRC pathway, and
this indicates that microbiome may serve as a useful disease
monitoring tool because we saw
that even among patients with polyp removal after colonoscopy,
the microbiome changes remain. So this can help us
better monitor patients to identify the high-risk patients for
recurrence and post-colonoscopy CRCAnd
also diet and lifestyle modifications are really critical to sustain
or enhance the benefit of any microbiome-based interventions
for CRC prevention. So we saw the very strong
correlation between the microbial changes with the diet and lifestyle
factors. And in terms of the timing of the dietary intervention,
the earlier the better, because we saw that even in the early
phase of the colon cancer development, there's already the very
strong correlation between diet and the microbiome.
And finally, for individual dietary factors,
coffee may be particularly beneficial for improving colon cancer
survivorship and has a very substantial and
specific impact on the microbiome.
So with that, I would love to thank all my lab members and
collaborators, as well as the funding sources.
And finally, I just want to put up this slide.
I was asked to advocate this Cancer Prevention
Research Conference co-organized by American Cancer Society
and the Cancer Research UK. So for those of you who are
particularly interested in cancer prevention, after this conference, if you want to
learn more, please come to Atlanta in June to join us.
So with that, I would like to thank you for your attention, and I'm happy to
take any questions.
Thank you.
Questions.
Okay.
Thank you for your talk.
Did you see any correlates with patients that suffer
from Lynch syndrome?
That's a good question. In our analysis, we didn't include Lynch
syndrome patients, but that's definitely an important
question to address. Thank you.
Thank you very much for your presentation.
For the randomized trial, what sort of
stratification markers are you using?
Are you using, for example, alcohol intake as one in the
coffee
randomization? Or are you just looking at it just straight across the whole
population?
No, we didn't stratify by alcohol.
It's a randomized trial, so hopefully the alcohol consumption
will be balanced by the randomization.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
So you mentioned the fruits.
Yeah.
Have you standardized the fruits, for example, apple,
banana,
pear, or just they're all washed or not washed?
No, we haven't looked at the individual fruits or the fruits
at such nuanced level.
The reason I ask you,
because we noticed a few years ago,
there is a
fruit farmer.
He just eats everything without washing,
and he got Parkinson's disease. So we use a
fecal microbiote transplant,
then overcome his constipation and
also tremor. So he recovered much better.
So then based on this, we did the randomized trial,
36 as a control,
same food donor. Then 36, then health
donor.
So then the health donor, the Parkinson's disease
has dramatically changed. We just published last
month, signal transduction and the target therapy.
Thank you. Thank you for sharing that. I'll definitely check it out. Thank you.
Yes.
Kim Lin-Ashting, City of Hope. Any thoughts about the role of
fasting?
Can you be more specific, like fasting among cancer patients, or?
Yes, and the microbiome.
That's a good question. So, in our
population-based study, we just ask people to collect
a sample
at home, and we didn't
specifically ask
about fasting.
I'm actually not aware of how fasting can--
I'm sure it's going to have a substantial influence on the microbiome.
I'm just not sure how that may modify the diet and cancer
relationship.
Thank you for the question. Yes.
I was wondering if you could comment, excellent talk by the way, comment on two
other things that have been thrown out as potential causes related to the
microbiome and CRC. One, antibiotic use, and then the
Clostridium sort of
colonization that comes with that.
And the other, which is unfortunate for the last talk, which
is ultramarathoners having seemingly higher rates
of CRC.
Thank you. Regarding antibiotics, yeah, in all our analysis,
microbiome analysis, we did adjust for antibiotics.
And regarding marathon runners, I'm actually not aware of that.
Thank you for sharing. Check it out. Yeah.
Yes, please.
Hi, thank you for your presentation.
I have a question about the coffee consumption.
The results are really nice as you show them, but many
people drink coffee with additives like milk,
sugar,
I don't know, flavor syrups and all that.
Have you checked if this has a counter
effect on the protective?
Yes, that's a great question. So in
the cohort data we have, we didn't collect very
detailed data regarding the other additives to coffee.
But I have seen data from the literature suggesting sugar,
like adding sugar, particularly high amount of sugar, can
attenuate the benefit of coffee.
Thank you.
Yes.
Oh, actually, interesting talk. So, you know, for the people who cannot drink
coffee well, they are being taught that they are being caused the excess
of acidity, right? So I'm wondering
for the microbial population, have you tested if the pH
related to culture
population?So they favor a
different pH level?
Oh, that's a good point. No, we
haven't really tested the pH level.
To be honest, I'm not even sure in our stool kit that
we used for our study whether we can still test the pH level
because there are some preservatives added to the tube to
preserve the DNA, RNA, and the metabolites.
But that's definitely a very important question.
Thank you.
En Chung from Albert Einstein College of Medicine.
Thank you very much for giving very
concise and insightful
seminar. I'm curious for the microbiome and also
diet, basically the first two parts of your findings.
Did you see maybe findings like differ by the
tumor location, maybe from left versus right
and also colon versus rectal? So I'm
curious about that.
Yes. Thank you for the question. In our analysis, we didn't see
a substantial difference across subsets, but I'm not
sure.
Power is definitely an issue because even for the overall analysis, our
sample size is already limited, given the high dimensional
nature of the microbiome. So I know for
CRC, like in a large data set, we do see some difference
between proximal and distal colon cancer, but the more
substantial difference is according to stage.
So it seems like the
stage of the cancer is probably more influential on the
microbiome compared to subset.
Yeah. I'll ask a follow-up question for basically, I'm not sure-
We really don't have time. Sorry.
Thank you.
Sorry. But I'm going to break in with the one question from
here, which is, was there sufficient data from early onset
colorectal cancer cases to identify any specific
associations with the microbiome or diet?
Yeah, that's a very important and timely question.
So in our Nurses Health Study II cohort, at the time of stool
collection, almost all of
them are above age 50, but they are still in early like
around 55 years old. So,
we cannot really study the microbiome's influence on early
onset of cancer, but we can still interpolate by
stratifying by age. That's something we are working on now.
Thank you.
I'm not sure we're going to have time for this because I know that
we need to vacate the room. So if you could please, sorry, but
if you could just ask the question
and thank you for the audience. Thanks very much for all the great questions.
Hope you enjoyed the-